a Brit and an American swap countries to
try each other's Burger Kings this is
food Wars
so obviously you can get a Whopper meal
at a UK and a US Burger King but we did
want to get them in both countries and
compare the two to see the differences
this year of course is a standard
Whopper meal I believe it was the
regular size and this would be a small
in the U.S just a quick visual check I
mean the Whopper itself looks identical
to the Whopper that I'm used to seeing
in the UK really really no changes there
the toppings seem like to be the same
you get the Mayo the pickles the lettuce
the Tomato onions and of course the beef
on a sesame bun so that's yeah exactly
what I'm used to let's take a look at a
UK Whopper
looks exactly the same so that's good
same size yeah it's a big one right
same stuff on the inside oh like oh I
got a regular one I didn't get it with
cheese
which is rare for me
it tastes pretty similar to what I'm
used to the beef is like pretty similar
if not identical you still get like that
flame grilled thing that Burger King is
kind of known for American so far has
just been very like very creamy but
pretty much everything else is the same
overall very similar to the water that
I'm used to
exactly the same
which is good but the fries however your
fries are a bit different I think
honestly the fries this is a large
Whopper meal I was kind of expecting
bigger for the US you know there's like
a good portion of fries don't get me
wrong but I feel like in the US if you
order a large fries I was expecting like
a lot of fries they look pretty similar
to the fries that I'm used to they're
like fairly thick cut thicker cut than
like a McDonald's say
it's a pretty good fries I have to say I
feel like when I go to a Burger King in
the UK I'm not really there for the
fries the fries are just very much just
sort of add on to the meal these are
good these taste way better than the
fries that I'm used to from Burger King
I don't know what they've done
differently they're like quite
aggressively salted which I personally
really like but they're just like well
cooked there's like a little bit of
crisp on the outside
still quite nice and like fluffy on the
inside the U.S Burger King has the fries
are weird there's some sort of like
batter to them I can't describe it they
changed it years ago and and uh
they're more distinct flavor I don't
dislike them but they're not that great
these are these regular fries I think
like I prefer the UK Burger King fries
over the US once definitely and of
course the fountain Coke I hope that the
camera can capture the scale of just how
large this drink is I have a a big head
yeah I mean it's Fountain Coke it's fine
yes regular drink is so tiny I've just
been informed that a Whopper can be
considered an insult in the UK what does
it mean
that's funny
have you been have you been called a
Whopper before
someone called you a Whopper
I think generally speaking
fairly familiar pretty much what I'm
used to in terms of the burger I've
enjoyed these fries more than I enjoy
the British fries and the coke is too
big dial that back a little bit guys
calm down
here's everything you can get at a BK in
the US that you can't find in the UK
here are all the UK Burger King menu
items I cannot get in the US let's take
a look at the U.S beef exclusives we'll
start with this the Whopper Junior look
at this thing
I mean yeah I think it's just a scaled
down version of the Whopper it's got all
the same toppings on there now we're
going from one end of the scale straight
to the other we're going from the junior
Whopper to the triple Whopper as the
name suggests it is a Whopper but
instead of the one patty you get three I
mean I don't necessarily object to the
existence of a triple Whopper I will say
I've got some notes on the assembly
because there's no like layering going
on obviously a Whopper doesn't have
cheese this is literally just like the
toppings and then just three meat
patties back to back
so I feel like when you bite into this
you're just gonna get like a big
mouthful of just beef I mean I will try
it for science I'll take a little I'll
take a little bite of the triple
yeah that's kind of confirmed my fears
I'm also covered in mayo next up we're
off to Texas because this is a Texas
whopper in case you're wondering what
made this Texan it seems like they've
just added some jalapenos bacon cheese
and mustard to a standard Whopper I
don't really know enough about Texas
culture to know if that makes something
Texan or not I would have expected maybe
some like barbecue sauce if you caught
something Texan but they seem to have
not done that so we'll see
I'm a big mustard fan so I like the
inclusion of mustard on this yeah that's
not bad I don't know if I would order
that just over a standard Whopper but I
think it's better than a triple Whopper
this is the BK double melts with a
signature cheesy sauce instead of a slab
of cheese they just drizzled the excuse
me melted liquid cheese the melted
cheese is kind of like a nice texture to
it a slice of cheese but just as easily
suffice bacon double cheeseburger
XL Charlie two patties cheese in the
middle cheese in between I'm very smart
guys see it makes a difference it's
bigger than in America we have the
regular bacon double cheeseburger this
one is a little bit bigger
notes extra bitter so there you go
yeah I I like this
and I would probably get this if I went
to Burger King I think this would do
really well in America come on two big
beef patties dripping with cheese and
bacon and it's big it's like its selling
point is that it's big dude this would
clean up in the U.S if this is in the
U.S we gotta get U.S bacon look at this
come on guys look at this how like nut
pink this is
this is like oh this this Bacon's bad
then we have two more Burger exclusives
which are
the kings first up we have the single
quarter pounder King this is a single
quarter pound Patty with some onions
pickles cheese mustard and ketchup this
looks pretty good to me this looks like
a very classic hand Dugger which I'm
kind of here for I will say in general
what I'm really enjoying about all of
these Burgers is the pickles I feel like
American does pickles way better than we
do
I thought that was going to be better
than it was I don't know why I don't
know what's wrong with it there's like
quite a lot of onion in it it's like a
lot of raw white onion and then the next
one I think we might have had recently
on the menu or might still be on the
menu in the UK but is a bacon King
either way I thought this would be a
good opportunity to talk about fast food
bacon this is a double burger some
cheese in the middle and on top along
with a few rashes of bacon
some ketchup and Mayo let me just prize
a bit of this bacon off this burger
let me get a close look
so this
is the famous American fast food bacon
so I feel like the US and the UK do fast
food bacon and I guess bacon in general
pretty differently
this in the UK would be called a streaky
bacon rasher which is where you get the
kind of like thin strips as opposed to
back bacon where you have like a
medallion and then some strip coming off
it generally speaking in the UK fast
food bacon tends to be quite a pallid
pink fairly unappealing color and can be
quite floppy as well they don't have to
cook it basically for long enough I will
say this bacon has a lot more color on
it than I would expect to see from
British fast food bacon
that's pretty good I think that's
probably better than the bacon that I'm
used to from a British fast food chain
so far all the bacon I've had including
this one it just tends to have like a
better texture there's a bit more chew
to it it's just been cooked a little bit
longer I think also lends itself to
giving it a much nicer color and you
definitely get more of like a smoky
flavor from it that you would expect
from good bacon which I don't think you
tend to get from UK fast food bacon you
have the Gourmet Kings let's go oh fancy
first one Farmhouse straight from the
farm you got your rocket AKA arugula you
got your
pickled red onions and like a smoky
cheddar cheese right this is actually
this is a pretty impressive looking I
gotta say
brioche bun
all right here we go
the arugula or rocket kind of ruins it I
like it but um
it's like such a strong flavor it just
really tastes like
arugula rocket whatever it's having a
bite without it it's a lot better so
unfortunately remove those a little a
little much this one also has arugula on
it so oh let's get a look in there man
they got the uh we got barbecue sauce
crispy onions right
same same cheddar same fun cheddar the
rule are gonna still a little
overpowering but with the fun stuff and
this cheese is on it's really good like
the smoked cheddar this one's good I
would get this I like this so Steakhouse
over Farmhouse then we have a couple of
very adorable tiny burgers down the end
this one is the Rodeo Burger so we're
going back to the South for this one to
make this Rodeo they've added barbecue
sauce and some onion rings see the only
reason I can think of onion rings
counting is Rodeo is that maybe it looks
a little bit like a lasso
no lasso no no and then finally we just
have a double cheeseburger you guys got
the Memphis barbecue burgers single and
double go side by side you know we in
the US we got something called the Rodeo
Burger I don't think you have that uh
here where it's onion rings and barbecue
sauce and surprisingly good but it's
like the smallest thing it's like that
big but this is a good idea this is that
but like adult size yeah I gotta get a
bite but I gotta make sure I get an
onion ring in it so the uh this works
really well together there's always the
creamy Mayo the Mayo and the barbecue
sauce and the onion rings and the bacon
yeah dude this is good another thing
that would do so well in the U.S I don't
know I don't have this in the states as
you say I will say they have to rename
it it have to be like the Rodeo Burger
Deluxe or something I don't know what
about this is Memphis I mean the
barbecue sauce it's a sweet sauce I
don't know what makes up memphisy
specifically and I'm still in that clear
on why onion rings equals Rodeo then
we're into some chicken fish and side
options we'll start with these ones
which are chicken fries now I'm pretty
sure we can get these or have had these
in the UK before however when we were
recording this it seems as if the only
ones available are the Doritos chili
Heatwave version whereas these are the
old-fashioned classic ones these things
are great I love these
I don't want to know how they form the
chicken into long strips like this if
British people are familiar with
refrigerators the snacks kind of like a
bigger hotter version of those it's
great next up we have a chicken sandwich
option which is the chicken Junior as
Joseph's pointed out they love calling
things Junior
at Burger King in the U.S
personally
I think they should be called the prince
you know
you have the Burger King as the main one
the little one should be a prince surely
it's like a chicken duke or
Archbishop of beef it just looks like a
very simple chicken burger
that's pretty good the Mayo's quite like
yeah quite creamy and quite sweet
chicken Royale looks just like the
regular original chicken sandwich we got
at BK
uh longer though
oh wait but this one has cheese and
bacon
yeah this looks kind of upsetting
it's kind of a bummer okay Crispy
Chicken Memphis Style
I do like the Memphis style onion rings
and bacon and chicken with cheese that's
a that's a new combination right yeah
we are just yeah
I think because it's fried chicken
it like adds even more like
flavor to it with the bacon cheese and
onion rings it's a bit much but it
actually works pretty well together I
think we got to Memphis up some of our
uh
BK in the US
or just just call it Rodeo style it up
then we have a fish option the big fish
it's fairly reminiscent of like a phileo
fish from McDonald's and it's got that
kind of shiny bun I do like a good a
good fish sandwich
yeah that's really not bad the fish is
like fine it doesn't taste of a ton an
acceptable attempt at a fish sandwich
probably not quite as good as a filet-o
fish then we have a side option we can't
find in the UK it's mozzarella sticks
I feel like yeah we have now hit a point
where pretty much everywhere does it so
mozzarellastic what I will say is uh it
comes with a little thing of marinara
sauce which I think is the only
exclusive Source at a UK US Burger King
so we can do a very very short sauce dog
the sauce is pretty strong actually
another concentrated tomato flavor it's
almost like eating a tomato puree rather
than like a marinara sauce acceptable
mozzarella sticks I probably wouldn't be
rushing to order those again plant-based
Whopper I'm pretty sure I did this in
the US right but your guys's plant-based
meat is different than ours we have the
impossible
meet in the U.S so our impossible
Whopper impossible meat has a chemical
that
is under review you guys have a
different plant-based meat than we do so
let's see what it tastes like
it's not
bad
it's not flame grilled flavored enough
you know what I mean like the Whopper
the meat you just taste that
Grill smokiness charcoaliness whatever
you want to call it
and this it looks like they're cooked it
the same way but I'm not getting that
same flavor from this meat at all so
until it tastes like meat but it taste
like a Whopper it doesn't have that like
Smoky flavor to it so and I don't know
that's I don't think I think they're the
meat
I think you guys gotta like Flame Grill
it more or add the same Flame Grill
chemicals under this as you do the
regular meat this is noticeably
different than the uh than the UK
Whopper vegan chicken
um
this looks I mean this looks exactly
like the original chicken sandwich so
there's something weird in here
there's something weird to that flavor
I'm gonna take it alone
oh this is not a good sign
because meat is not easy to pull apart
ah
nah it just tastes weird it doesn't
taste like chicken
it tastes like it's flavored like the
chicken but the consistency of it is
just different I don't know I wouldn't
say it was like bad it just tastes like
it's not chicken these came and went in
the U.S so fast I didn't get a chance to
try them
but now I finally do looks like a nugget
yeah it just tastes like a fake
something or other maybe bad like the
batter on this seems thicker than
regular nuggets so I'm getting almost
all batter flavor which I guess isn't
that big of a deal this doesn't taste
like chicken again it says it's like
blank it doesn't have much flavor to it
yeah I mean I think you guys got to step
up your chemical game because our fake
meat tastes way better and these are
chili cheese bites
exactly
it's mostly ooh a little bit of heat to
them too the jalapenos yeah these are
good on to the fries cheesy fries oh man
this look this this looks this is like
really phoned in this is really phoned
in no effort on that look at the bacon
like it's not crispy it's like right
this is the bacon you they have in an
omelette station to put in your omelette
like pre-diced or whatever but this is
like you guys it's got to be crispy or
nothing come on nothing to it really
seems like a waste all right sauce talk
time got the sweet chili and the Smoky
Barbecue there's also a spicy mayo
wasn't available at the Burger King we
went to oh well it's time for sauce talk
foreign exchange
sauce talk first one sweet chili boys
sweet chili is having a moment in the UK
it's growing on me I think Switzer is
really nice Smoky Barbecue
oh this is uh in collaboration with
Bullseye steak sauce or barbecue sauce
was a big player in the sauce game a
decade or two ago but I kind of feel
like I haven't seen Bullseye in a while
um
pretty good they're over Us exclusive
breakfast items from Burger King we'll
start on this end what we will find
breakfast biscuit sandwiches now if you
saw the McDonald's episode you'll know
that I didn't really like their version
of a breakfast biscuit this is the ham
egg and cheese you can also get a bacon
egg and cheese or a sausage egg and
cheese now I'm still not convinced by
the notion of a breakfast biscuit to the
UK mine this kind of looks like a scone
I will say this one kind of like feels a
bit more buttery and a bit more moist
than the McDonald's one did so maybe it
won't be as bad
it's hard to tell if this is actually
like a scone or not this has more of
like a sort of bready texture than a
scone does for the British audience I
feel like a scone tends to be a bit more
crumbly and doughy whereas this one is
more bready as for like the flavor there
is a pretty similar flavor I would say
in the sort of main taste you get is
butter I don't know it's pretty good
next up we've got the crust sandwiches
now for the uninitiated like myself this
is a breakfast sandwich but instead of a
bun or a biscuit they use a cut in half
croissant these come in the form of
bacon egg and cheese a sausage egg and
cheese a ham egg and cheese or you can
get a fully loaded option which comes
with all of the above you get the bacon
you get the ham and you get the sausage
patty coming from a country that is in
pretty close proximity to France I feel
like I do have to speak up on behalf of
my uh my French friends out there
because yeah they just look a bit sad
really I will say I kind of have more
faith in this idea than a biscuit
because at least a croissant like will
be hopefully flaky and buttery pastry
and not quite as dry as a biscuit will
be I will say there are some places in
the UK that will do like a ham and
cheese croissant but it's usually like a
full-size kind of crescent-shaped
croissant which I would just cut in half
and then add the cheese for the ham and
then toast it
um these like I don't know it's the fact
that they've got the small circular ones
so they've clearly been purpose built to
be buns I'm not really sure about that
I'll try the big boy I'll try the fully
loaded croissant which
it's actually not the worst delivery
system because it's like it is quite
thin it is quite buttery and you do get
like a little bit of the flakiness that
you'd expect as much as I kind of
disagree with the concept of a cross
sandwich if you made me choose between
one of these or a breakfast biscuit I do
think I'm choosing these because it's
closer to just like you know a sandwich
for all the croissant sandwiches you can
also get a double meat version so you
can get double meat of the bacon of the
sausage and of the ham I don't think you
can get a double fully loaded version
because that would just be kind of
insane then we have two breakfast
burrito options we have the eggnormous
burrito and the breakfast burrito Junior
if this is Junior then is this his dad
and my favorite thing to do is just
invent fast food law I'm not 100 sure
what's in either of these so let's find
out
oh well some sausage
oh god oh no
oh god oh oh there's like rice in it I
mean I've really made a I've made a mess
of this I'm sorry guys so I'm seeing uh
what looks like half a sausage patty
some egg
and what I think is rice
ah give it a quick quick try
that's a reasonably palatable breakfast
burrito and then the big boy the egg
normas right what do we got in here
bacon quite a lot of rice I'm not saying
any sausage in this one I'm pretty sure
it's just like egg bacon and rice let's
give it a quick try
it's okay so to me this does taste a
little bit like claggy and hard to chew
its way through
however I'm told it's supposed to come
with a salsa verde which I think they've
forgotten to give me so maybe if I had
like a salsa with it that would uh ease
the digestion a little bit also this is
called the egg enormous burrito but it's
really not very like this is not
enormous guys come on if you're gonna
call something enormous we're in America
I want properly enormous and then
finally we have some french toast sticks
what is Burger King Us's beef with
France they're really just going for
France here so I don't think I've ever
had french toast before it's not really
a thing in the UK so in the UK we have
eggy bread or egg bread which is
different with stuff eggs but it's like
a Savory thing because we're not putting
like vanilla and cinnamon and stuff in
it I will have like basically just egg
in bread that I will throw in a pan and
then maybe he would like some ketchup
I'm being told I have to try this with
the syrup
so let's give that a go
British person tries french toast for
the first time
[Music]
I mean it was pretty good yeah
this is even more egregious than like
pancakes
because this is like it's like a churro
that you then dip in syrup somehow
that's for breakfast not convinced if
that is a breakfast food or not but it's
very tasty one last thing to note is
that at a U.S Burger King you can
actually buy several Burger options
before 10 30 a.m while they're still
serving the breakfast menu they will
also make you a Whopper and I think a
bacon King I'm not really sure who wants
a Whopper at like 9am there's obviously
exclusive Burger King breakfast menu
items but since the pandemic a lot of
Burger Kings are still working on a
reduced menu they're almost nowhere to
be found we looked apparently you're
only finding them in like service
station locations so we looked around
um couldn't find a place to serve them
sorry here are some drinks that I can't
usually find in the UK we'll start with
this one which is high sea fruit punch
that's such a deeply unnatural color
my British palette has not adjusted to
American soft drinks yet because this
thing is aggressively sweet this one's
Dr Pepper I can't remember if this is on
the UK Burger King menu or not but I
mean I like Dr Pepper in the UK let's
see if it's the same in the US
okay and it's actually that's pretty
comparable Burger King in the US also
has some milkshake options this one is
the Oreo cookie shake this comes highly
endorsed by Joe did you say this was
your favorite fast food Shake I would
say yeah one of my favorites yeah one of
his favorites yeah High Praise let's
give it a try
I mean yeah that's delicious
that is so thick the straw like
almost isn't up to the task yeah that
really does taste like Oreos
like the filling of the Oreo and then if
that's not enough chocolate for you they
also have a chocolate Oreo cookie
milkshake I mean yeah it's basically the
same as that but I think but just with
chocolate ice cream instead of vanilla
ice cream is the base yeah I don't think
you need to mess with the formula stick
with the classic stick with vanilla okay
for drinks Burger King's in the UK I
also have tea and espresso and the one
by two didn't have hot drinks and they
also have various Capri Suns which they
did have and we did order and they
forgot them then we have some Burger
King desserts that we can't find in the
UK we have two options firstly chocolate
chip cookies seems like these come in an
order of two which have cemented
themselves together they don't look
brilliant they're quite uh
but like hard on the outside
I don't know if cookies are supposed to
make that noise
those are like quite over baked then we
have a slice of Hershey's Sunday pie I'm
kind of intrigued by this it's come
pretty highly recommended to me I like
the packaging this is quite fun don't
bite your nails kids
makes it very hard to open Hershey's
Sunday pies I really don't know what to
expect from this but I guess I'm just
gonna like get a scoop out and see what
happens
is it like pastry on the bottom
I can't really figure out what's going
on this I think like a sort of like a
cakey biscuit base type thing yeah that
is very rich but also very tasty
if there's one menu item that I could
keep and take back with me to the UK I
don't actually know if it would be a
specific menu item or maybe more like an
ingredient I think I would take the
bacon that you guys have at a US Burger
King and take that back to the UK
because I feel like here it actually
adds something to a burger in terms of
like texture and flavor whereas in the
UK it's just kind of there like you
don't really notice it and if there's
one menu item that I would delete from
all possible Burger King menus I think
it would be that triple Whopper I think
it just really was everything that was
wrong with American fast food in general
it's just kind of excess for the sake of
excess you don't need that much meat you
need some kind of like lubrication in
there it's just dry chewy horrible
get rid of it you've tried all of our
Burger King menu items which one are you
taking back with you to the US I think I
like the Memphis Barbecue
Burger is the best because it was like a
Rodeo Burger but it's bigger added more
stuff on it so I think I could really
get into that
what was oh that that that fake chicken
the chicken Royale specifically is the
consistency of the chicken how it tasted
it just tasted off tasted really weird
like my body was like
do not swallow spit out now so I feel
like it's a nugget version it would work
but as the chicken Royale
didn't work it's Gotta Go
Joe from food Wars I'm in the UK so you
know what that means I'm visiting Burger
King I want to see what it's like
compared to my usual U.S Burger King
experience put the GoPro on here just to
make everyone a little uncomfortable
including myself so let's go get some
Burger King